the ice coffee hour interview is  probably my favorite interview the first  one that's probably the favorite  interview I did I think is there some  internal external stuff so externally it  was the first time that I talked about  like kind of like My Views around the  world and I think that with a certain  percentage of people that resonated with  them because a lot of people don't  articulate what they believe for fear of  getting attacked I mean myself included  which is why I hadn't done it and so I  think that was like the external thing  that happened but I think internally  because of the positive reception  overall that I got from that particular  podcast it made me feel a little bit  more comfortable kind of sharing more of  probably like the contrarian views that  I think have contributed to a lot of the  material success that we've been able to  achieve and think a lot of that stuff is  like you cannot have common beliefs if  you want to have an uncommon life